- All right, let's close out
with something super fun,
and pulled right from the
virtual pages of Instagram.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So as you may know, I'm a
proud baby of the 80s, y'all.
That's right.
It's the era of such
distinct and amazing styles,
such as leg warmers, off the
shoulder, oversized sweatshirts
and velcro high tops, if
you were super classy.
Well, one Connecticut man has encapsulated
some other huge trends
of the 80s in his home.
So he redid his newly
purchased 1890 farmhouse.
top to bottom with all
the pastels, flamingos,
and palm trees that your heart can desire.
He says it's Barbie's dream
house meets Miami 80s motel
meets Golden Girls, and
it's simply amazing.
We have this visionary
designer on the line right now,
watching on NBC 4, New York at three.
What's up Johnny?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly! How are you?
- Hello! Oh my God, I love your house.
So in the past two years
you've completely
transformed this home, right?
So take us through the highlights.
- Yeah, so my partner and I,
we bought our home in the
early stages of the pandemic,
and girl, it needed a glow up.
I mean, it was spooky okie.
I'm talking, the walls were beige,
the floors were beige.
And so, day one of owning the house,
I busted out the pink
paint, and went to town.
We then started to go to estate sales,
and found really cool vintage 80s pieces
and sort of, designed each
room around the pieces
that we are sourcing.
For instance, the living room was designed
around the pink couch,
the kitchen was designed
around the big, blue fridge,
and the master bedroom was designed
around no other than Miss Piggy herself
with her glamour shot.
She's the first thing I see
when I wake up in the morning
and she says, "Honey, we are
going to have a good day."
- I love that.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much, Johnny.
We love your house.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience cheering)
All right, and that's not all my, man.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion
the go to erasable pen,
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
and amazingly so, just like you.
So they're giving you a thousand dollars
just for being you, man.
(audience cheering)
- Are you kidding?
- Well, thank you Johnny,
and thank you to all our guests today.
(audience cheering)
Kit Hoover, Frida Gustavsson, Kelly Rizzo,
Isaiah, Jude and Ronnie.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.